to politics now early voting continues
this week and as we approach election
day a lot of voters still have some
questions and we've tried to get some
answers for you with the primary on the
way mary jane bellies spoke with a local
voting advocacy group to get some
answers for us good morning mary jane
john good morning to you while voting
it's not more easier now when mail
imbalance became a bigger part of the
election process during the pandemic i
spoke with one local voting advocacy
group in clark county sandra cosgrove
from vote nevada says many people don't
know where to go with their voting
questions which can discourage people
from voting if they don't know what to
do the nonpartisan group encourages the
community to give them a call to help
educate them on the voting process
people are nervous about making sure
their mailing ballot gets counted and so
all you just need to make sure is you
know
well we know how to do the bubbling
because we all did scantron tests when
we were in school so people aren't too
confused about the bubbling part but
they're like i know i need to sign
somewhere where is it
it's on the back of the envelope you
need to look into your sample ballot
find what's convenient for you what we'd
like for you to make use of your sample
ballot since we send it to you
there are many ways you can turn that
ballot in there is a postage paid stamp
on your ballot to mail it or you can
drop it off at any drop-off location as
well you can also call vote nevada at
702 that's
803-1569 if you have any voting
questions live in the newsroom mary jane
balleza live local now